now let's discuss the difference between
a live connection
and an extract connection first it's
important to note
that these different types of
connections are not available
in tableau public it's always a live
connection and a live connection
is where the data will update based on
when
the source of the data updates so if any
if you're connected to a database
and something in the database changes
then you'll pick up those changes when
you open the report as
it will query that database when the
report is opened
whereas an extract connection is
extracted into creates a subset of the
data
that improves performance so when you're
looking at it locally on your computer
you have an
extract of that data set that subset of
the data
right on your computer or up in tableau
server depending on where you're looking
at it
and it does not update when the database
updates it only updates when your
refresh
updates it so without a refresh set for
that
extract you won't get the new data
as an example of this let's say that
in our sample superstore we have
kelly williams associated with the
central region but that's changed so
let's go ahead and change that
we will change it to
smith and we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in
over here in our extract it sarah smith
doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet 1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in
so that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day
or once every several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau
so here we have the people table but
let's say we want to join it to our
orders information
so i'm going to start with our orders
table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on
based on the names in the two data
sources so
if these two data sources didn't have a
column that had the same name
then tableau wouldn't be able to guess
what
two to join on so we would have to come
in and select
out of the order side and the people
side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join
a right join and a full outer join let's
review quickly what these look like
so say we had two tables that we wanted
to join together
one of them was the student table that
had the student names
and the key to their grade and which we
could use to look up their grade
over here in the grade table which had
the key to their grade
and the actual grade a b c d f and
incomplete we can see here that somebody
has made a mistake
and put in a letter grade instead of the
key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take the rows where the
join
could complete so we have one
that could join to one just fine but we
don't have two and we don't have 3
a doesn't join to anything so this row
would be
not included and then 4 5
and 6 would all join so that would look
something like this
where we would see adam when we grab
student
from this table and grade from this
table we can see adam had an a
beverly had an a dale had a d elizabeth
had an f and frank is incomplete
and charles is missing also you don't
see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join it's going to take
everything
from the left table and only the pieces
from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar
to our inner join only charles shows up
so the join wasn't able to complete
since a doesn't exist in grade
but we include charles anyways and grade
becomes null for charles it won't put in
the grade key because it's we're not
asking for the grade key
we're asking for grade from the grade
table so
we try to look up a inside of the grade
table we can't find it and never
tolerance
no we look up a inside the grade key
perfect
right join is like a left join only it
takes everything
from the right table instead of the left
table
so it grabs all the grades a b
c d f and incomplete and only the rows
from the left table
that join appropriately so since charles
doesn't join appropriately he doesn't
show up
we also have b and c showing up
even though it doesn't exist in the
student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables whether or not the join is
complete
so we have all of the people where the
join completes
we also have charles where the join
doesn't complete from the left to the
right
and we have b and c where the join
doesn't complete from the right
to the left so those are our options in
tableau
here in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table
that don't exist in the people table and
that's how you can know what kind of
join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up
even though they don't have a region or
their region
is not in the people table
that's when you would do a left join for
our purposes
we'll do an inner join now let's say
we had a second excel sheet
here that had more orders
and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders by
dragging
that second orders table right
underneath the original orders table
you can see it says their drag table to
union and that's helpful for if you have
an excel sheet
for maybe different years so say you had
a separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015
and then another one for the orders in
2016 you could pull on your 2015 orders
and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders
and then add the rows instead of the
columns
for the 2016 orders thank you for
joining us today for any questions
please visit
www.simplylearn.com or post any
questions below on the video
thank you and have a great day
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here